moving on our main story tonight
concerns the corona virus among other
things the worst thing to happen to
weddings since flashmobs
and the reason we're talking about it is
that we have a huge Kovach related
catastrophe that's actually just around
the corner hide routes of tenants
rallying this week demanding rent relief
they warn the next few months could see
the largest number of eviction cases
ever yeah as if things weren't already
bad enough in the middle of a pandemic
we may be about to see evictions on the
rise and on the list of things you hope
never to see on the rise evictions have
to be right up at the top tide of course
with Larry King's penis that thing going
up is just not what our current
situation requires and while evictions
rising is shocking it was also
completely foreseeable coronavirus has
played havoc with employment making it
difficult for many to make rent which
was always going to have significant
consequences given that about 1/3 of US
households are renters and renters tend
to have lower incomes than homeowners in
the first place and while stimulus
checks expanded unemployment insurance
and state and federal moratoriums on
evictions undoubtedly helped hold back
the tide those mechanisms and now
starting to run out or expire and if we
do nothing experts are predicting
horrific outcomes with millions of
people left vulnerable this is the worst
economic crisis the United States has
seen in generations if nothing else
changes and evictions continue as normal
and this public health crisis will turn
into a full-blown hominis crisis it's
true the coronavirus crisis could also
soon turn into a full-blown homelessness
crisis and it's hard to even fathom
something already so bad transforming
into something else so appalling it's
like finding out that magikarp
objectively the worst pokemon for
obvious reasons is set to evolve into
Kevin Spacey I should have traded you
for Psyduck when I had the chance and it
says something about the utter absurdity
of what's about to happen that this is
how some eviction hearings will be
taking place starting with tomorrow's
docket judge Lopez will start hearing
eviction cases either in the court using
webcams with the defendant and the
plaintiff in separate rooms
/ zoom or even on the phone what are you
doing you know it might be worth
thinking twice about what you're taking
part in if you're throwing people out of
their homes via zoom a platform you're
only using because it's not safe for
people to leave their homes
besides zoom shouldn't be where you find
out that you're getting evicted it
should be where you find out in a
virtual happy hour which one of your
co-workers has been secretly rich the
whole time I'm sorry
Johanna has a chandelier where did she
get chandelier money why don't I have
chandelier money look the fact is we're
about to go out of our way to throw
people out of their homes at the worst
possible time and even in normal times
evictions are incredibly damaging with
long long-term effects on the community
level they've been linked to heightened
residential instability substandard
housing declines in neighborhood quality
and job loss and on the individual level
they can be completely devastating in
ways you may not even realize from
families losing their possessions and
having to start over to significant
difficulties in obtaining new housing
something that can be hard to do with an
eviction on your record Vick shion's
have consequences that can haunt you for
the rest of your life so tonight with
rent due in just three days we thought
it might be a good time to talk about
evictions and let's start with the fact
that the lack of affordable housing is
yet another systemic problem that the
coronavirus has thrown into harsh relief
because to be clear it was a crisis in
this country long before the pandemic
struck with rents so high and renters so
burdened that stories like these became
a staple on local news a chaotic scene
as hundreds make a run for the door and
a chance at Dallas County housing
vouchers at least eight people suffered
injuries while trying to line up this
morning
jordon Spivey's all scuffed up after
taking quite a tumble this morning but
grateful she wasn't trampled to holy
no one should ever be trampled by a
crowd of people out of desperation to
get rental assistance there are only two
times when trampling is remotely
acceptable the day after Thanksgiving
that's America's national trampling
holiday and whatever day in the future
the ps5 comes out I don't care that it
looks like an alien's waffle maker or a
penguin designed by Apple it's gonna
have horizon forbidden West as an
exclusive release and I will stomp
anyone who stands between me in that
game I want to murder dinosaur robots
with flaming arrows and a want to do it
now now that particular Stampede was
nearly a decade ago but unfortunately
the problem has only gotten worse since
then rents have risen significantly
faster than incomes to the point where
for renters below the poverty line the
majority are spending more than half of
their income on housing and a quarter
are paying 70 percent or more which is
just not remotely sustainable meanwhile
around a million households have been
evicted each year for over a decade and
all of this disproportionately impacts
people of color as black households for
instance are twice as likely as white
households to face eviction and women of
color particularly black women are
especially vulnerable to it so things
have clearly been bad for a long time
but once the pandemic hit like
everything else they got even worse and
yet you might have assumed that there
was a freeze on rent payments if you
listened to decomposing melon larry
cudlow laying out the Trump
administration's plans back in March
don't forget also please regarding
things like rent payments or rental home
loans all that will Vic shion's let me
add that all that will be put on hold
there will be no evictions during this
period now that sounds great especially
if what you took from it was no rent no
evictions but that's not actually what
he's saying there the policy he's
describing only paused evictions not
rent meaning that for those unable to
pay the bills they owe have just been
piling up this whole time also the
policy only applied to certain
properties like those with federally
backed mortgages which
for just a quarter of all rental units
so as far as comprehensive plans to stem
this crisis it leaves a lot out much the
same way in fact that larry cudlow wife
leaves a lot out of her many paintings
of her husband's clothes specifically
what she leaves out is her husband
because as we've mentioned before on
this show
there was simply nothing that she likes
to do more than paint her husband's ties
over and over and over and over again in
a joyous celebration of the absence of
larry cudlow and quick side note here
when we first brought this up months ago
we offered anyone 10 US dollars plus a
$20,000 donation to their local food
bank if they were willing to sell us one
of these genuine Larry les masterpieces
and everything's being so busy that we
haven't had the chance to reveal
something to you and that is we actually
got one and let me tell you the absence
of Larry is even more striking in person
look the point is the federal moratorium
on evictions left a lot of people
unprotected and while several dozen
states put in place their own
moratoriums many of those protections
have already expired leaving renters in
23 states with no state-level protection
from eviction meaning many tenants are
forced to rely on the kindness of their
landlords some of whom to their credit
have worked with their tenants and
reduced the rent owed or have stepped up
in even bigger ways like this guy
Mario Salerno owns roughly 80 apartments
in his hometown of Williamsburg he knows
the pain so many are going through so he
decided this month to waive rent for
everyone everyone 200 tenants and he is
not collecting for me it was more
important for people's health and
worrying about who could put food on
whose table I had tenants that said they
can't work they didn't have money to pay
me I says don't worry about paying me
worry about your neighbor that's great
that's very generous but unfortunately
the solution clearly can't be to count
on everyone being like that guy if for
no other reason and if everyone was like
that guy we'd be forced to make a
sopranos reboot that was essentially
just oops
all
and nobody wants that not even Silvio he
bolted his brief tenure being the
skipper he couldn't handle the crown
let's just let him stay where he's
comfortable and the truth is rather than
emulating that guy some landlords have
gone the opposite way even trying to
threaten tenants despite the protections
in place
kortnee is still in disbelief as she
reads through the most recent emails
from her landlord she says on March 31st
she told the landlord who lives in
Canada that April rent would be late
days later just pay the rent or move out
the email started you lying both you and
your grandmother can go online and
yourselves Wow
that isn't just horrifying it also
effectively demolishes every Canadian
stereotype I've previously held because
it seems there's a new type of Canadian
that none of us have known about in it
the hard-hearted bad boy who tells you
and your grandma to go yourselves
no luckily that woman's governor had
ordered a freeze on evictions for those
affected by Kovac which covered her
situation and when that local news
reporter pointed that out to her
landlord his response was pretty
remarkable he sent us a colorful email
in it he apologized for the profanity
and eventually said he's willing to
waive her late fees plus half the April
rent which he would lose anyway if he
had to find a new tenant and they can
both get on with quote our miserable
lives ok whatever you think of that
landlords behavior I will say this that
is just objectively the correct way to
end any email in 2020 happy virtual
graduation now let's get on with our
miserable lives Congrats on the new baby
now let's get on with our miserable
lives my deepest condolences on the loss
of your grandmother she lived a long and
miserable life and now she'd want us to
get on with Arliss and the thing is even
when landlords and property managers
obeyed to the moratoriums they often
made it painfully clear the tenants were
going to be evicted at the first
available opportunity I'm notoriously a
landlord that doesn't generally invite
tenants get by with any exception even
as court hearings are temporarily on
hold he's moving forward with filing
evictions and attempting to collect
it's never fun throwing you know
throwing a single mother and their three
kids out on the streets that's not fun
but it's business okay first of all
Never Say Never
what if the three kids in question were
baby Hitler baby Stalin and Donald Trump
jr. and that single mom was Galen
Maxwell that's a pretty funny vixen
right there that foursome could frankly
use a little time on this street but
what is happening in that example is
actually really important because many
of those moratoriums prevent the
physical act of eviction but they don't
stop the legal process that leads up to
it many landlords and property managers
have been able to file for evictions in
court this whole time meaning cases have
just been piling and piling and piling
up and as soon as moratoriums are lifted
which is already happening in many
places evictions could come fast and
some landlords will tell you that the
current situation simply isn't there
thought and that their tenants should
have somehow prepared better one
property management company actually
made that argument to a local denver
news crew who then played the audio to
one of the company's tenants and just
wait until you see his response maybe
you shoulda say for the rainy day just
saying yeah that's a fair point because
why are renters consistently the only
ones being told that they should have
planned better it's important remember
everyone is in this crisis together
right now and this isn't just a rainy
day it's the great flood and one reason
no one has an umbrella is because it's
not safe to reopen the umbrella
factory yet and in the face of an
extreme crisis some tenants are
understandably calling for drastic
measures like rent strikes we are out
here today to demand that the city the
state and the federal government cancel
the rents we need rent cancellation
every month we're accumulating more and
more and more debt
so there's no way we're going to be able
to repay that back a lot of us are
already choosing between food and right
we're saying to choose food the same way
they bail out banks they should have
bail out working families like mine yeah
of course we should absolutely treat
families at least as well as we treat
banks who can apparently like Wells
Fargo just re-establish themselves
whenever they get in trouble in fact
next time your landlord asks you for
your last three months of rent why not
tell them that they're mistaken that
rent was owed by the previous you the
current you was reestablished on July
1st of 2020 and you're ready for a fresh
start and look rent strikes are a risk
ultimately you could end up being
evicted for non-payment which remember
could make it harder to get housing in
the future and depending on your
landlord situation they might be unable
to meet property taxes to go toward
funding essential city services so they
are not without consequences but you can
see why many have been pushing for them
or indeed for rent cancellation because
people are desperate and strikes have
been an effective way of calling
attention to how dire things are right
now and while long term we desperately
need a plan to fix our affordable
housing crisis in the short term we just
have to find a way to keep people in
their homes and although some cities are
trying to provide rental assistance the
limited funds at their disposal make it
difficult to address the scope of the
problem take Houston they established a
15 million dollar rental relief fund and
this is what happened fifteen million
dollars gone in just 90 minutes money
that was dedicated to help families pay
their rent during this pandemic we're
not able to accept your application for
the green and Trevor had applied for
1,800 bucks and rental assistance they
won't be getting that help though
because by the time they applied online
this morning the money was already gone
15 me not going within an hour come on
now yeah it's shocking to watch 15
million dollars disappear in 90 minutes
I mean not quite as shocking as watching
one hundred and seventy five million
dollars disappearing around the same
time but still you know shocking and the
thing is the city of Houston knew
in that this was going to be an issue
they even tweeted after the fact we
understand this is nowhere near enough
to meet the need of all houstonians and
in fact the city directly encouraged
people to reach out to their
representatives to advocate for greater
funding because the truth is cities can
only do so much without federal
intervention but they have essentially
the same amount of power as the servants
of downton abbey' sure they'll do what
they can but at a certain point when
things get really bad they're gonna have
to take this upstairs now in a much
bolder move the city of Ithaca New York
is currently the process of trying to
count salt rent for those affected by
this pandemic and it's calling on the
state to provide funding for landlords
who need relief and that is an
interesting idea although again it
requires the people upstairs like the
state and ultimately the federal
government to act and unfortunately they
have dragged their feet on offering
solutions for renters that remotely meet
the scale of this crisis back in May to
its credit the House passed the heroes
Act which provided a hundred billion
dollars in rental assistance for the
most vulnerable unfortunately since then
the bill has stalled out in the Senate
which is frankly no surprise as multiple
high-level Republicans have expressed
their reticence to pass another relief
package I think that many people would
like to just pause for a moment and take
a look at the economic impact of this
massive assistance program if the
economy continues the momentum that
we're beginning to see over the last
couple of weeks of data that I think
that one might conclude that the
stimulus that we've already passed is
enough we need to assess what we've
already done take a look at what worked
and what didn't and we'll discuss the
way forward in the next couple weeks Oh
in a couple of weeks really well here's
the thing that was back in May we're now
at the end of June nothing has been
passed and rent is due on
Wednesday that said I do know the time
simply does not function the same way
for Mitch McConnell as it does for
everyone else for instance for us today
is June 28th but for him based on the
way that he generally thinks speaks and
behaves the current date is somewhere
around May
12 1853 and look sad truth is we've
already waited too long here and there
is absolutely no excuse for not
attacking this problem with real urgency
because while we wait for Congress to
act people like this woman having to
deal with the consequences Kiana Ashley
is being evicted and a nightmare is
unfolding for her and her five-year-old
son Nazir that's something I wouldn't
wish on my worst enemy because not
knowing where you're going to rest your
head up from the next day that's not
good yeah of course it's not good
everyone deserves the basic stability of
shelter and if you are in a position
where you've begun to despise the house
that you've been shut inside for the
past three and a half months it is worth
remembering the only thing worse than
knowing you're gonna spend another day
stuck under the same roof is not knowing
that and while there are clearly no
perfect options here the very worst
thing that we could do right now is
nothing because every day we fail to act
is a day that we're compounding another
future crisis for millions of vulnerable
renters and their communities we need to
stop this before it gets even worse and
in a long-term we badly need to solve
our affordable housing crisis because
then and only then if I may quote the
world's rudest Canadian can we all get
on with our miserable lives
you